[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is the brand new htc u ultra and it is
definitely the shiniest phone of all
time and this happens to also be htc's
first big smartphone of 2017 and it's
coming to the us with a price tag of
749 so this is definitely a high-end
flagship smartphone and people who buy
700 android smartphones these are the
pickiest of the bunch those are the
biggest enthusiasts people who want the
biggest baddest phone they can possibly
get so this seems to be what htc is
setting the tone with those people with
so it's rocking pretty high-end specs
the snapdragon 821 through adreno 530
gpu four gigs of ram and quality
materials all around i mean you haven't
seen many phones like this that are
basically a mirror finish on the back
it's glass and metal it's got the htc
skin over android 7.0 some sweet colors
are available and the cherry on top is
of course how great this thing looks so
this thing might be a sleeper of a great
phone but the more i look into it the
more i use this thing the more i
understand the ultra the more i realized
this seems to be
a really poor use of space this is a big
phone i mean you look at its footprint
compared to things like the iphone 7
plus the galaxy note 7 and even the
pixel xl which stands for extra large
and is bigger than all of those and even
others with even smaller displays it's
bigger than all of them and it's still
eight millimeters thick so it's also
definitely not trying to be a super thin
phone in any way either so it seems like
there should be all the room in the
world to throw in every possible
flagship feature and perk right well
you've probably already realized this
even if it's in your head without me
saying it the back of this phone
definitely resembles another certain
rival's flagship
not the galaxy s7 the galaxy s6 back
when there was a big hump on the back
for the camera and the galaxy s6 that's
when it looked the most like the ultra
but of course the next year samsung made
the phone a little bit thicker with all
its new upgrades and bigger battery etc
and ended up with a much smaller camera
hump on the back there should be no need
for such a big hump on an even bigger
phone of the ultra so the camera bump in
an already huge phone to me seems like a
poor use of space and for the record
just having a camera bump isn't always a
big deal but on the ultra it is and then
there's the headphone jack or the black
of a headphone jack yeah no headphone
jack at all in this huge phone now i
understand usb type-c is great and it's
the future and everything but apple's
main reason for getting rid of the
headphone jack in the iphone besides
courage was to save precious space in
such a compact interior of a phone other
manufacturers have since continued
putting headphone jacks on their phones
because they don't need that space and
the portless future isn't quite here yet
in htc you definitely could have also
but you didn't for some reason seems
like a poor use of space and then the
battery the htc u ultra has a 3 000
milliamp hour battery which doesn't seem
that bad but for context
yeah something's a little bit off here
you would think that a phone this huge
and this thick with this much internal
space would have all the room in the
world for maybe a two-day battery life
maybe the biggest non-removable battery
they could possibly fit but that was a
missed opportunity here and this phone
is stuck with average battery life at
best
seems like a poor use of space and even
if i get a little picky these these
buttons down here at the bottom of the
phone have some pretty small touch
targets and i can't help but think that
something just looks a little bit off
about them a bit out of place to the
point where it took me a little bit of
time to actually get used to pressing
them in the right spot with a screen and
a phone this huge htc could have easily
gone with on-screen customizable
software buttons or at least given that
option somewhere in the menus it's 2017
but they didn't instead they went with
these small permanent capacitive buttons
way down at the bottom now they could if
they wanted to drop that in a software
update so i won't rag too hard on that
if they want to enable it but maybe they
just wanted to have buttons on the side
flanking a fingerprint reader because
they just really wanted a fingerprint
reader which is cool you can put one
there but they managed to put one of the
smaller ones on any flagship phone even
on one of the biggest phones out there
seems like a poor use of space this 750
phone is also not water resistant and
with a body and all the internal space
this big you would think they would be
able to find the space to put the seams
and the seals to make sure that it's
water resistant just like a lot of the
smaller flagships out there but they
didn't
seems like a poor use of space and if
you look in the sides and the corners of
this display especially up at the top
left corner right underneath the webcam
you get some serious light bleed and i
hardly ever notice actual light bleed in
any flagship smartphone i don't know if
it's because in this phone the back
lighting is too close to the display
panel or if the insides are too clumped
up there next to the webcam to get that
space evenly lit i don't know what the
problem is but it is actually noticeable
and that rarely is a problem for me on
smartphones so it seems like a poor use
of space again it's also a huge phone
with tiny speakers at the bottom sure
it's a stereo pair but it's definitely
not the loudest and it's definitely
tinny at high volumes poor use of space
you see what i'm getting at also most
glass back phones like this have
wireless charging that's why they do it
if you have a metal phone you can't do
wireless charging because wireless
charging doesn't work through metal but
if you have this sort of a big glass
back and a huge amount of internal space
you would think you could at least have
wireless charging but it doesn't pory
space now even all of that isn't the end
of the world i mean there's phones that
are also lacking all those things i just
talked about but they're all also less
than this price so i think at 750
dollars in the us it's pretty hard sell
i mean people who are buying phones at
that price are looking for something
really special and i don't think you're
getting that here i mean there are
definitely some good promising things
about this phone that have me psyched
for htc's next phone the camera in this
guy is really good it's a 12 megapixel
ultra pixel camera and has face
detection auto focus that's really fast
and photos look very good they can
almost go toe-to-toe with the google
pixel so i'm really impressed with that
it also has expandable storage which is
definitely rare in most smartphones and
appreciated in a high-end flagship and
the second display up at the top while
it is a shameless rip of the lg v20 it's
also kind of useful sometimes like the
one in the lg v20 you get some app
shortcuts up there if you want i kind of
like it when the display is off and i
raised to wake and i just get that
little bit of notifications and the time
and the date that's my favorite feature
of the second display but you know if
you don't want to use it you can turn it
off as well so there is good stuff here
but aside from new htc software there is
almost nothing for 750 bucks that this
phone does that you can't get somewhere
else better or cheaper so with that i'll
say skip this one and you could pretty
easily wait for the htc 11 to come out
pretty soon or just grab a galaxy s8
when that comes out or an lg g6 or
pretty much any other 700 smart fund
which will be a better use of space than
this one so that's been it hope you
enjoyed feel free to leave a comment if
you agree or if you have some other
stuff to share thanks for watching talk
to you guys the next one
peace
[Music]